[Music]  a fearless warrior  in a world without sight everyone close  to you  always ends up suffering  [Music]  now it's your turn brother  i swore i would never return here but he  took my daughter  [Music]  where she came from  i need to find out where he's hiding  [Music]  here  [Music]  we are chosen to usher in a new world  i carry within me a child born with  god's gift  of vision  [Applause]  sight will return the first nation to  harness its powers will dominate the  world  we are declaring war on the greatest  military force in the world  this is not our fight if we walk away  thousands of people will die  [Music]  i know this enemy i was this enemy  they fight to enslave respectful freedom  i say we open our gate right now  and welcome them to hell  [Applause]  [Music]  there are weapons more powerful than  sorts  they look the key to our future  welcome home bubba  you